now the film you're going to see is the
creation of three artists band leader
Paul Whiteman who was the most popular
band leader of the entire 1920s I mean
we're talking Beatles level compared to
everybody else enormously popular a
studio chief of universal Carl Laemmle
jr. he became studio chief at the age of
21 and he wanted to make his mark and he
did with all quiet on the western front
in this film and director John Murray
Anderson and I'll share a little
background on John Murray Anderson John
Murray Anderson was a New York stage
director of reviews which shows with
musical numbers comedy but no plot and
he started with the Greenwich Village
follies and his shows in the 1920s were
the equal of the ziegfeld follies and he
also worked with his production designer
Herman Raza on Broadway shows like the
1929 John Murray Anderson's Almanac
which had many of the elements that
found their way into king of jazz the
next year in 1925 Anderson was recruited
by paramount to produce stage shows that
would be part of the program in publix
theaters and in two years he directed 50
of these 30-minute little mini stage
shows so if you remember footlight
parade the James Cagney character he
puts on these prologues live prologues
in the movie theaters that's what John
Larry Anderson did for two years and
that's where he met Paul Whiteman and he
first worked with many of the vaudeville
acts that appear in king of jazz and so
two of the three big numbers in king of
jazz originated in these shows for
publix theaters he staged early versions
of the rhapsody in blue and melting pot
for publix and used other elements like
a giant piano in some of the other
prologues and he had also used the stage
the bridal veil number on Broadway as
early as 1920 so while king of jazz
captures Paul Whiteman at the peak of
his career it also provides a glimpse of
what a public stage prologue and a
Broadway revue would look like as staged
by one of the great Broadway directors
of the 1920s so now we're going to see a
fantastic restoration of the 1930s
you